pas de médecin traitant donc on ne
prenait pas de médicaments vous avez une
maladie particulière vous êtes
diabétique hypertendue lorsque vous
composez le 15
votre appel arrive ici voici le centre
de réception et de régulation des appels
du samu au bout du fil
ils sont cinq le matin quatre l'après
midi et de la nuit
si nécessaire ces agents transmettre
votre appels aux médecins présents à
leurs côtés
mais lorsqu'il ya surchauffe le public
attend parfois quatre ou cinq longues
minutes
insupportable lorsqu'une vie semble en
jeu le st1000 france l'audi de pouvoir
répondre le dans l'appel dans la minute
prendre l'appel de décrocher dans la
minute est à l'heure actuelle vu le
nombre qu'on est con 23 nous permet pas
de tout le temps répondre dans la minute
bien sûr comprend des appels dans la
minute mais il ya des appels des fois
qu'ils vont prendre deux trois minutes
être décroché imaginez une personne avec
une personne en arrêt cardiaque de morel
qui attend trois minutes au bout du fil
pour avoir un accès sans régulation
médicale chaque minute qui passe en
effet le patient en arrêt cardiaque perd
10% de chances de survie et il en est
ainsi dans de nombreuses situations
le 15 est en première ligne face à la
maladie aux accidents aux violences pour
gérer ses urgences vitales aujourd'hui
les agents veulent passer de 23 à 27
pour réduire le temps d'attenté
quelqu'un qui va appelé pour une urgence
vitale qu'il estime être une urgence
vitale pour nous ça en a on a l'oreille
on est formés à ça et donc on à
l'oreille qu'il faut pour entendre là
la douleur est l'urgence par contre au
niveau de la tante d'appel on ne peut
pas savoir quand on a une personne en
ligne la raison de l'appel de l'autre
personne qui est en attente et qui
entend là le message d'attentes de
prison en appel qui est mis en attente
on a eu ce cas très récemment où une
jeune femme a été retrouvé pendu
malheureusement on n'a pas pu la sauver
parce qu'elles étaient déjà tendues
depuis trop longtemps et on à cette
détresse qu'il faut pouvoir gérer
en 2018 le quinze de martinique a
transmis sans 46500 appel au médecin
régulateur ses revendications 5 un jour
supplémentaire
la titularisation 17 contractuels et
l'extension de la prime de 100 euros
versés aux urgentistes les arm d'y subir
autant de stress voire de menaces des
usagers mécontents au niveau des temps
de réponse on n'est pas au temps de
réponse idéale mais on s'en rapproche
énormément
et après ça le stress au travail oui
c'est un c'est un travail qui est lisse
excessivement stressant les gens
téléphonent dans des situations où ils
ont portes pour un proche est
effectivement au téléphone et une
certaine des inhibitions et certaines
personnes peuvent être très agressive
donc effectivement le métier d'armes
n'est pas un métier facile
la discussion est ouverte assure la
direction du chum
d'autant que le 15 est bien le numéro
mise en avant par les autorités
notamment pour réguler les entrées aux
urgences